to tell us more about wild afro day and
indeed why it is needed uh its founder
michelle deleo and the uk's first ever
black female swimmer for team gb alice
deering join us on the program ladies it
is wonderful to see both of you this
morning and i have to say usually i'm
pretty confident heading into to most
interviews but on world afro day as a
bloke with a white face i'm going to
defer to you on all of this michelle
just explain the concept behind world
afrodane and how it got started
yeah so it's a global day of change
education and celebration around afro
here because really there's just been a
legacy of a lot of negativity that
affects us on so many levels so that's
jobs that's education that's opportunity
and simply because we've got different
hair type goes up and out like mine so
that shouldn't be an issue but
unfortunately it is
alice
why from you from your own experience
we've got two very different kind of
hairstyles being modeled at the moment i
mean from from your experience why has
there been that this this negativity
because again you know i come from one
of the whitest parts of the whitest
nation in the united kingdom i come down
here to london and i get really quite
surprised by the attitudes that some
people have towards afro here
yeah it's just interesting i suppose
because it's different and or it's seen
as different in some parts of britain
and then especially if you're a minority
in a group of white people
it can be quite difficult when you know
your hair doesn't grow in the same way
it doesn't like just go down it goes up
or curls a lot like it has for me so um
yeah it's just a shame that um black
women and black children like sometimes
feel like this but um i think world
afroday is absolutely great because it's
giving us a chance to change all these
negative words and negative feelings
that people have had about their afro
hair and give them a chance to celebrate
and realize how beautiful it is
yeah indeed michelle i i suppose then as
much as anything a key part of the
strategy has to be as we're just hearing
from alastair getting in touch with
younger people getting in touch with
them at a point where perhaps attitudes
for the rest of their life are set when
perhaps bullying is more prominent than
it may well be in later life it's it's
getting in and helping out the younger
lot isn't it
yeah it's really true because um our own
research hair equality report but other
research shows that school is the number
one influential place on how children
feel about their afro hair one in six
children feel bad uh they're having bad
experiences in school so we don't want
that to continue so we work with schools
you work with teachers today we're doing
the big hair assembly a live streaming
event across the world 184
000 plus young people uh black white
asian every
every
kind of background are coming together
changing negative views and increasing
positivity and inclusion and because now
we have a world sponsor like pantene uk
we're able to actually reach more people
with that positive message this message
is for everyone we can all feel positive
about afrohair um
alice i i wonder you know given your
experience in this swimming pool i mean
was that was the hair ever an issue when
when you were in there and and also just
whilst we have you i mean isn't it the
case we do i do certainly feel like i'm
seeing more of my black colleagues
wearing their hair naturally these days
that that does seem to have kind of
grown over the over the past couple of
years
yeah so definitely yeah first with
swimming um i have struggled with my
hair in the past and so i used to relax
it when i was younger we'd relax it
twice a year and then braid it like
periodically in between and yeah
eventually i was just like i'm done with
this went and got the big chop so i got
rid of all the relaxed hair and embraced
my natural hair and i found it so much
easier and yeah at the moment i've got
braids so
um it is a bit different but i'm
managing it it's absolutely fine it
doesn't put me off swimming
and yeah in terms of
people embracing their hair it's
absolutely amazing to see i get such
hair envy um like yeah like this video
showing gets such hair envy when people
are out with their hair and just being
proud of it and it's just so great to
see that it's really being embraced and
we've moved into such an amazing time
for
our generation to
really show how beautiful it is